so this story is going to be partially
funny and it's going to be partially
serious because there are funny things
to talk about here and serious things to
talk about
there are numerous social media groups
and accounts and pages targeting both
the David Pakman show and the majority
report with sam cedar claiming to target
us from the left which have cropped up
recently one such group this is just an
example okay just to give you a sense of
what I'm talking about one such group is
a Facebook group called progressives
against Sam cedar and David Pakman and
there are some funny things on the page
for example if you look at the header
image cartoons of Sam and I a word
bubble from Sam saying Joe McCarthy 2020
and me saying yes please
then there's another group called anti
McCarthyism progressive unity against
Sam cedar and David Pakman and of course
there are endless Twitter accounts which
I mute when I see them because I don't
have time for them and youtube comment
movements pylons which are lately
targeting Sam and me from the so-called
progressive indie media but sometimes
they're targeting more people too so
sometimes Sam and I will be targeted
including Kyle kolinsky from secular
talk as being part of the problem
sometimes Kyle is part of the solution
but Sam and I are part of the problem or
sometimes they will include Tom Hartman
as part of the problematic left-wing
media along with Sam and with me but
sometimes Tom Hartman is the right type
of progressive he's on the good side of
the line but Sam and I are on the wrong
side of the line but the point here is
that who is on which side of the line
changes and it depends hugely on which
so-called progressives are drawing that
line and that's not hugely surprising
now I'm trying to think of like how to
even start with this because when you
see something like this progressives
united against David Pakman and Sam
cedar there are a bunch of obvious
questions that we should be asking
question one is are these groups really
people who are on the Left who dislike
salmon who dislike me or are they
right-wing astroturf that's a question
to be asked second who is it that these
so-called progressive support if Sam and
I are the
who were the right progressives that
should be supported according according
to the people who are creating these
groups targeting salmon targeting me and
thirdly what does it mean about the
progressive movement that more and more
stuff like this type of infighting and
targeting is cropping up so here's the
common trends I'm seeing when you look
at the anti David and Sam pages number
one many of them have a ton of Pro Jimmy
door content posted as examples of the
right kind of leftism
okay so if we look at progressives
against Sam cedar and David Pakman a
whole bunch of the posts are Jimmy door
clips which I believe is meant to imply
that Jimmy's the right kind of
progressive and Sam and I are the wrong
types of progressive so right off the
bat you start to get a picture of this
anti Sam and David movement as at least
partially a pro Jimmy door movement
often these pages and particularly the
Twitter accounts also have a lot of Pro
tulsi gabbard content if you don't know
Tulsi Gabbard she is a presidential
candidate currently polling about 0.6
percent I believe so that's another sort
of trend that exists and then typically
there's a lot of Russia Gate denialism
that is in a lot of these anti David
anti Sam pages along the lines of we
can't believe anything Muller says other
than when Muller said no collusion but
all the stuff about obstruction and
election interference and WikiLeaks is
involvement from the Moller report that
stuff we don't believe but we can
definitely trust Muller that Trump did
nothing wrong so I'm not gonna go back
and attack any particular wing of the
left I'm not going to accuse certain
leftists of not really being left
because that would be furthering the
problem that these groups are sort of
indicating exists here's my main point
if the left continues to do this the
left is going to continue to fail on
many fronts and I brought this up on the
Joe Rogan program two weeks ago and a
bunch of people misunderstood what I was
saying when people come to me and they
say David what's the real problem with
the left it's not sjw's okay it's not
campus free speech suppression it's not
toxic identity politics those things
exist
and they do exist in bits and pieces on
the left and I call them out when I see
them but the real potential problem on
the left is defining the left so rigidly
that it will fail to accomplish anything
major because it will keep out way too
many people who share most of our goals
and there's a really good article by
Joshua cites in Politico from June 1st
called progressives should read
progressive history so they don't blow
it this time
and it points out that there are major
problems to solve right now in American
society in the American economy but if
progressives want to achieve change we
need to understand how Past movements
have succeeded and the article looks at
the progressive movement of the early
1900s and it looks at the New Deal
coalition of the 1930s and it also looks
at the conservative coalition of the 70s
and 80s which was really successful for
conservatives and I won't go into the
specifics of the three movements right
now but the general thing they did right
is they were inclusive of people who
disagreed on some of what should be the
agenda but they agreed on enough of the
important stuff that they were able to
get really important change to happen
and that's my real concern about the
progressive movement right now and I'm
going to talk about this at the end of
the week in audience questions the lines
are being drawn too narrowly and people
who could work together on for example
70% of their agenda or 80% of their
agenda are going to end up doing nothing
because they're concerned about making
pages targeting other people on the
basis of the 10 or 20% that they
disagree on one example okay small but
growing is this divided on the left
between social democracy and socialism
it's a great debate philosophically it's
a great debate economically I'm glad to
have that debate social democracy versus
socialism I've engaged in that debate on
the show the u.s. is not going to become
socialist any time soon and before the
US will have a reasonable possibility of
becoming socialist it's going to have to
move significantly in the direction of
social democracy the reforms that are
possible in the immediate our reforms
that are social democracy reforms
which should appeal to the actual
socialists socializing healthcare
raising the standard of living for the
bottom via taxation at the top end of
financial transactions that had no value
to the economy and education what is the
point in redirecting energy away from
making those changes which both Social
Democrats and socialists agree on in
order to debate and draw the lines
between you're either with the
Socialists or you're against us this is
stupid
ok the left will lose if that's what
they do let me give another example that
applies to me I am against intervention
in Venezuela 100% I've said it a hundred
times but I also think that the Shah has
made aura regimes have been terrible for
Venezuela ok we agree on the Left almost
100% about being against military
intervention in Venezuela and yet when I
bring up but by the way I don't like
Maduro and Chavez and here's why and I
think that they have been disastrous
plunderers for Venezuela all of a sudden
I'm on the wrong side when it comes to
the intervention piece and people are
ignoring the fact that I'm right here
with you I'm against military
intervention in Venezuela let's work
together on that because the debate over
Chavez and Maduro has less in terms of
immediate consequences than that about
American intervention in Venezuela
so let's table some of the less
mediately relevant discussions let's
actually get stuff done that we all
agree about and let's not draw the lines
too rigidly because that's the problem I
see on the left not free speech campus
stuff or sjws or whatever those problems
exist I call them out they're relatively
small but anyway have fun with the anti
Sam cedar anti David Pakman groups but
you are doing damage to the movement
unfortunately